did you always dream that you were gonna
be an actor was just something from when
you were a kid I thought I would be
involved in I knew I was not cut out for
the workforce in a normal way I was no I
just knew my attention span was off I
said there's something there so you feel
like kind of a misfit but I did have a
sense of humor but but the thing is when
you wrote rocky yeah and and then final
I mean you were broke and you write
rocky and the studio is like you finally
get acceptance and they say okay look we
don't want you say I want to be the star
this money and they go look man you're
nobody that's true you turned on how
much money for them to just buy them
just by the film input I don't know who
they want to put in there to snow
whatever right on the hill Jimmy Caan
they wanted to put Nick Nolte did people
say to you listen Sylvester you'll get
your chance to act sell the movie make
some money including my agents they said
are you crazy
this is ridiculous money $360,000 by
standards back then no I said look guys
I I really mastered the method of living
on nothing of eating basically cobwebs
and it's okay I'm not I I know in my
mind if I sell it now and it becomes
good kill yourself I will kill myself
dude how long how long did you have to
hold that knot in other words they say
to you here's three hundred sixty
thousand dollars for writing rocky go
away and leave us alone about about
three months but to the here's what's
different in Hollywood the producers
there went against the system and had to
mortgage their own houses mortgage their
houses to get the money up and get the
studio behind him in the bond the
guarantee try that today good luck who
did you pressure like who is what studio
and who is the United Artists United
Artists and they've sat down you said we
loved your script but you cannot do this
walking away from three hundred sixty
thousand so when did you get the call
that finally okay well we'll let you
start it you have to go audition for
them we know what it is if they finally
broke it done said we can do this film
if you're gonna be in it
we have a 14 that no he's a 14 day thing
where we can fire you anytime if you do
anything wrong and and more importantly
we can reduce it down to nine hundred
grand all in and if you can do the thing
in under thirty days okay if not it's
it's over so shoot the whole thing in 28
days 28 days the whole first rock whole
thing unbelievable I know it is
why can't I do that every time either
what happened it becomes too important
it becomes too important if you would
just knock out movies like that without
all that in that great a failure in a
sense I know it's like what happened
it's great when you're working out
there's change in the back of a pickup
truck at all there's a certain kind of
energy about it and you don't become so
caught up in my right anger my make up
this and that and things happen that are
so visceral but you're right as we
become more pampered more spoiled more
reserved we take a little longer against
it it said this is right and you know
what you lose your edge you lose your
edge there's no doubt about it
everyone's best work when you were
starving five years you wrote how long
did it take you to write rocky I mean
literally sit down and start writing it
well it took about this'll sound
pretentious but took three days of which
90% was terrible but the German the idea
was there right that was it so and then
after that it took maybe 25 rewrites you
have to keep going like one day you say
can we make the black guy Jamaican we
make this guy so you have to and then
you come back pow pow
two and three BAM big grab you didn't
write the first Rambo yeah what I did is
it was based on the book though no Rama
Rama had been around for actually I
think that we're going to lab animals
before they got to me they went through
every actor in the system and they
eventually said okay DeNiro thing Nick
Nolte zippy the monkey let's go to sly
right and this is a career killer right
this film when we did it it was so bad
at least I thought right and even my
managers we both went out I think we
both retched together in the alleys it
we tried to buy it back and burn the
neck which Phil my children we tried to
buy it back and burn the neck you
thought it was a bad movie what
originally it was three hours long I
stayed an hour and a half in the woods
chasing guys
and plus I was pontificating throughout
the thing for example I shoot an owl and
then the albatross I go take that you
mouse munching mother oh I said I can't
say and then there be lines like the cop
pulls me over them because what do you
think you're going I go
did you ever see Easy Rider yeah well
yeah I'm easy Walker so I not forced a
movie well I said here's a good idea cut
out all my dialogue every every line and
have other people talk about you which
by the way is it's not a bad way to live
in general oh by the way all the great
movies made all the heroes and hardly
say anything exactly right
other people fill in the blanks like a
Greek chorus you know and I think that
works and then when you saw it playback
you said this is a good miss works again
you know how it went from three hours to
90 minutes that's great eight minutes
this is so great